let this circle represent $1,000,000
this is what ten million dollars would
look like this is what one hundred
million dollars would look like and this
is what 1 billion dollars would look
like Jeff Bezos the founder of Amazon
has a net worth of 117 times this number
and then there's you you're probably
working a job right now one that you got
from the degree that you studied for in
university you probably don't have much
in savings your living expenses seem
ridiculously high you feel as though
you're not paid enough you have credit
card debt that needs taking care of
maybe your student studying for a degree
that you ho can and your job that you
hope can bring some good money you
probably don't have any savings only a
pesky student debt hanging above your
head wealth getting rich that all seems
like a distant dream how did they do it
you ask yourself seeing all those
millionaires billionaires especially the
ones who got there at such a young age
it baffles you it makes you angry they
got lucky they were born into well they
cheated their way to that money doesn't
make them honey as evil and you're not
smart and I'm just unlucky those dreams
you had of buying that mansion your
favorite sports car paying off your
mortgage traveling around the world
they'll forever remain that way just
dreams
nothing more nothing less you come to
the harsh realization it's a rigged game
it's been a rigged game from the start
in you you're on the losing side of it
but what if I told you you were wrong
what if there was a way of getting there
an actual equation to wealth a science
behind the way money works what if you
didn't have to abandon those dreams of
paying off your parent's mortgage or
traveling around the world would you
call me a liar for saying so I promise
that I'm not and by the end of this
video you'll understand there's a side
to the coin that you're not being shown
but I warn you the road is tough it's
filled with struggle it's filled with
ups and downs it will need swallowing
some difficult roofs of the school
system and society haven't told you yet
and let me be clear there are many of
you who will not make it to the end of
this road but for those of you that do
at the end of this road lies wealth
beyond what you thought you could attain
at the end of that road lies the freedom
of never having to worry about money
again so are you with me
[Music]
[Music]
still with me then let's not waste any
more time what do you really think about
money is this something you work for is
it earned or is it inherited is it the
root cause of all evil are you desperate
to have more of it have you been chasing
it most of your life truth is most of
what you think about money has been
influenced by your upbringing and
environment if you were born into a
family that didn't have much money
growing up then you're more inclined to
believe that YouTube will not grow up to
have much money
or perhaps you went on the complete
opposite end and decided to make as much
money as you can so that you will never
be in that position again
the fact that your school didn't teach
you much about this subject doesn't help
things and because of this most of you
are going to have false beliefs about
money that aren't going to help you on
this journey
now stick with me here because we're
gonna have to change the way you've been
seeing money your whole life Hollywood
has always had a habit of depicting the
wealthy and rich as evil backstabbing
entitled or corrupt individuals question
is have you bought into that stereotype
a recent report released by Wealth X
showed that of the world's ultra wealthy
those that had a net worth of 30 million
or more 68 percent of them were
self-made and it seems like every other
study backs up this conclusion Warren
Buffett self-made billionaire Howard
Schultz born in poverty Oprah Winfrey
born in poverty Jeff Bezos self-made
billionaire Elon Musk self-made
billionaire Sara Blakely self-made
billionaire what is it that these people
know that you'd on truth is your
equation is all wrong here's the
2-dimensional equation that you've been
taught money equals salary earned from a
job past a certain point the prospect of
getting a job becomes the sole purpose
of your education so what's wrong with
that you ask I'm gonna assume that if
you're watching this you want to make
money a lot of it and in a short amount
of time as possible if that is your goal
then this equation for generating money
will never get you there we all have
a precious resource the most important
resource for Hall and once it's gone
there's no way of getting it back that
resource is time in a standard job the
amount of money you burn is dependent on
the amount of time you put into that job
if you earned $20 an hour and worked 40
hours a week it would take you nearly 24
years to reach a total of 1 million
dollars but that is without subtracting
any taxes or any expenses that you will
incur over 24 years and let's not forget
that inflation would make your 1 million
dollars less valuable the reality is
that on a salary of $20 an hour you can
only really be a millionaire at an old
age by living frugally and most of that
precious resource known as time has
slipped through your fingers you traded
all that time for money and it wasn't
even a substantial amount either so
again you ask yourself how is it then
that there are self-made millionaires
and billionaires that such young ages
what makes them so different and the
truth is they have a better equation
than you they have a way of
understanding money that you haven't
quite grasped the earth
[Music]
pay very close attention now stop
chasing money in a capitalist society
the rules of the game are as follows you
are paid in proportion to the perceived
value that you have and the people that
perceive your value they are the market
the consumers of the economy the market
is you your friends your family your
neighbors your country people complain
that football players are overpaid but
for players to be paid millions there
has to be a market for the football
industry in the first place people have
to see the value in football in the
first place for them to want to spend
money on matches and merchandise and if
the market is a high demand for football
guess what happens to the players who
are at the top of their game they are
paid generously for it it's not about
how hard you work the cleaner that
sweating and tiring himself out every
day is paid far less than the accountant
sitting behind a desk why because the
market perceives the value of what the
cleaner does to be far less than the
accountant as harsh as it may sound the
cleaner can be replaced by anybody it
isn't difficult to learn how to do his
job and therefore the market will not
pay him more than the accountant the guy
who spent years studying numbers the guy
who has saved his clients thousands on
their taxes but even so we just
discussed how getting a job is in the
right equation to amassing a great
amount of wealth in a shorter period of
time so then how can we increase or
perceived value what is it about people
like Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos that makes
their perceived value so high the first
step to this equation of wealth is quite
simple if you want money solve problems
if you take a second to digest this
statement you realize that just about
all money runs from this basic premise
if it solves a problem money will be
thrown at it if it's a million-dollar
problem then the solution will make you
Millions
if it's a billion dollar problem then
the solution will make you billions
think about all the problems that our
site like Amazon solves the hassle of
going to a store that hassle of having
to wait weeks for a delivery cheaper
prices and so on not to mention all the
other
companies that Amazon bones and the
problems that those companies solve Jeff
Bezos helped solve a billion-dollar
problem and also awarded favorably for
doing so if you've been chasing money
then you've been doing it all wrong it
sounds almost paradoxical but if you
want money it isn't money that you
should be looking for you should be
looking for problems and more
importantly solutions to those problems
and once you found that solution make a
business around it wait so that's it
just solve problems and money will
appear so I'm gonna have to create the
next Amazon for me to be rich or the
next Facebook or Google you've got to be
kidding me right I don't even know how
to code I don't even have the money to
start something of that scale
I don't even hold on your wants more
going into old patterns of thinking
start with a problem always start with a
problem listen to the market around you
what are people saying they don't like
what are people saying they wish existed
what are people saying frustrates them
what do people think is incredibly
inconvenient is that a problem that you
can solve and also is a problem that is
worth solving
[Music]
the final step of this equation to
wealth is finding a scalable solution to
the problem your solution needs to
affect a magnitude of people starring a
restaurant that's not scalable you're
constrained to the local area and the
footfall of that area but a franchise
now that's more scalable is your
solution a piece of software then that
means once that software has been built
you can scale it infinitely online
without needing to worry about things
like production or shipping costs as
it's all done virtually good luck
finding infinite scale with a job but be
careful does your solution require your
time to generate money let's say you
were a yoga teacher that charged $100
per hour congratulations you only made
yourself another job disguised as a
business there's only a certain amount
of lessons that you can feasibly do in
one day and therefore your income is
time-bound but if you created an online
yoga class that ran 24/7 with lessons
you only had to create once
now that is scaleable scaling your
solution is critical here so do not get
lost on this point automation also plays
an important role systems and processes
will keep your business running like a
smooth machine if implemented properly
if there is something in your business
that you can outsource to somebody else
or hire an employee to do it for you
assuming it financially makes sense for
you to do so then do it tasking yourself
with everything is a bad thing as much
as you may think you're the best there's
someone out there that can do a better
job than you once you've found a
solution it's your job to make sure that
solution can be accessed by everyone in
your market it's not about your ego and
it's not about what you're passionate
about the market doesn't care about your
passions so now that you have your
profitable business running with the
right systems and processes in place
it's time to move on and reap what you
sow
[Music]
there are two likely paths you're going
to face at this point you either
continue your business or cash in and
seller this is the acquisition the
moment someone buys the solution that
you spent years building a business
around this is Instagram being acquired
by Facebook for 1 billion this is PayPal
being sold to eBay for 1.5 billion of
which 165 million went straight to Elon
Musk's pocket and the countless other
liquidation events that happen across
the world this is where all the effort
that you spend into building your
company comes to fruition and if you
choose to continue running your business
well there's a multitude of reasons for
you wanting to do so maybe you love the
company that you built will want to
stick with your baby maybe you think you
can add more value to the company and
sell it down the line for more than it's
currently worth perhaps that business
runs passively in the background so you
don't have to do much to keep the wheels
turning or maybe it's a combination of
these three things either way you did it
you solved a problem that the market
wanted solving and it were awarded you
favorably for doing so and so now I ask
you what was it all for anyway
for most of you it was never about the
money money is just a piece of paper a
number on a screen its value is only
backed up by our belief in its value
from the very start this was never about
the money paying off the mortgage buying
your dream car traveling around the
world never having to worry about your
financial situation it's the freedom
that you were looking for your
destination wasn't anything monetary
related it was a feeling a sensation the
ability to do what you want whenever you
wanted without ever having to cast the
thought towards can I afford this have I
used up all my holidays for the year how
am I going to pay the rent will I be
able to live off my pension what dreams
will I have to sacrifice because I can't
afford to pursue them the most important
lesson from this video was never about
the nature of money it was about the one
valuable resource that we all have the
one resource we will never be able to
reclaim time is giving up a large chunk
of your time towards a job that you
probably don't like worth it is your
life settled on working coming home
watching the telly sleeping waking up
the next day and repeating the same
cycle till you retire how many more
hours of your life do you let slip
through because of this pattern or
perhaps you're fine with that reality
perhaps you have no other choice but to
follow that path for the time being and
if that's the case there's nothing to
worry about
the most you got from this video was a
little entertainment and maybe a change
in perspective but there are those of
you that understand the other side those
of you that have the desire to never
need to worry about money ever again and
so I feel the need to remind you stop
chasing money chase problems and find
the solution to those problems this is
the equation through which all money is
found if you desire Liberty through
never needing to worry about money ever
again
then let's solving problems be the
meaningful struggle in your life does it
mean you'll be happy at the end of the
road doesn't mean you'll feel fulfilled
only you can answer that question
but if your struggle is meaningful then
perhaps it's worth pursuing
[Music]
and there is your equation to wealth of
course I missed out on a lot of
intricacies in this video the topics of
business money entrepreneurship are far
too vast for me to cover in a single
video like this but if you do want to
get started on this journey I do
recommend you read the works of MJ
DeMarco who heavily inspired me to
create this video and it's also
important to come back to an original
point that I made at the start of this
which is that most people will not
succeed for various reasons but the most
important part is failing failing fast
and moving on to the next thing and if
you're out there doing something that
isn't strictly related to a business but
you want it to make money then asking
yourself the question of what problems
am i solving could lead you to find ways
of better monetizing whatever it is that
you're doing and that also includes a
job and a career if you can solve more
problems and find more solutions at your
place of employment you have something
that you can use to leverage a higher
salary but I will end this all on the
same message that I have repeated
numerous times in this video stop
chasing money and start chasing
solutions to problems
[Music]
hey you've arrived at the end of the
video and thank you so much for watching
but don't click off just yet I do want
to take the time to say thank you very
much for watching to the end these
things take quite a few sleepless nights
to research script film and edit so you
can't imagine how much I really do
appreciate your support if you genuinely
enjoyed this video then don't be shy hit
the like button and if you disliked it
hit the dislike Vaughn twice just to be
sure and comment down below and let me
know why my goal with this channel has
been to create entertaining documentary
style videos on business finance and
life in general and if that sounds like
something you'd be interested in and
you'd want to tune in for more hit the
subscribe on and hit that notification
belt make sure all your notifications
are turned on both all of that being
said I hope you have a wonderful rest of
the day as per usual my friends hand
ahead salute
[Music]
you